famous boxer is ready to jump into a
different ring this time local politics
we're talking oscar de la hoya talking
about running for mayor of las vegas
sports director chris matthews live in
studios with more on this possible
mayoral run chris yeah thanks guys oscar
de la hoya seems interested and wouldn't
uh be the first for these guys there's
been a handful of professional athletes
who have moved from politics and some
are very successful at it former
champion acquired a huge following here
in las vegas he fought here 27 times and
now wants to be the golden boy of
fremont street outside the ring he won a
grammy and after his boxing career
became a successful businessman
promoting fighters now the former champ
wants to fight for las vegas as your
mayor
there might be some opportunities in
vegas to run for mayor really oscar de
la hoya mayor of las vegas well i'm
actually uh building a home in in vegas
and uh i obviously should have done it a
long time ago
but uh yeah it'll be interesting to uh
to see if i can uh make a run for may or
in las vegas all right one year ago this
month de la hoya was looking to fight
former ufc champion veter belfort that
never happened time will tell if there
could be a second oscar named mayor of
las vegas and